EVERYBODY.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
WE SPENT MONTHS NOW ASSESSING
THE CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC, MOSTLY
FROM A MEDICAL STANDPOINT.
WE NOW KNOW A LOT MORE ABOUT THE
VIRUS THAN WE DID BACK IN MARCH
AND FEBRUARY AND WE ARE GRATEFUL
FOR THAT, FACTS ARE ALWAYS
BETTER THAN SPECULATION.
BUT IT’S POSSIBLE THAT IN DOING
THAT WE SPENT MAYBE TOO LITTLE
TIME CONSIDERING THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY, THE MANY MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS WHO WILL NEVER FACE
SERIOUS HEALTH RISKS FROM THIS
VIRUS.
SO THE QUESTION IS, AND WE
SHOULD BE ASKING THIS A LOT, HOW
ARE THEY DOING?
WELL, MORE THAN 30 MILLION OF
THEM ARE NOW UNEMPLOYED.
30 MILLION.
THAT IS SO MANY PEOPLE THAT IT’S
HARD TO DIGEST WHAT IT MEANS, OR
WHAT IT’S GOING TO MEAN FIVE
YEARS FROM NOW.
FOR SOME CONTEXT, THAT IS DOUBLE
THE JOB LOSS FROM THE GREAT
RECESSION OF 2009.
THAT TOOK US TEN YEARS TO
RECOVER FROM, MANY NEVER DID
RECOVER.
IN FACT THE ENTIRE MIDDLE CLASS
NEVER RECOVERED, SO HOW LONG
WILL 30 MILLION TAKE?
IT’S A TERRIFYING.
IN FACT, IT’S TOO SCARY FOR MANY
OF OUR LEADERS TO CONSIDER.
IT IMPLICATES THEIR JUDGMENTS,
THEIR POLICIES, SO THEY’RE
DETERMINED TO IGNORE THAT
QUESTION AND THEY’RE EVEN MORE
DETERMINED THAT YOU IGNORE IT
TOO.
YOU’RE ABSOLUTELY NOT ALLOWED TO
THINK ABOUT THAT, MUCH LESS TALK
ABOUT IT.
HOW MANY TIMES IN THE LAST WEEK
HAVE YOU CLICKED ON A VIDEO A
FRIEND SENT ONLY TO DISCOVER IT
HAS BEEN DELETED BY YOUTUBE,
GOOGLE, BECAUSE IT CRITICIZED
PEOPLE IN CHARGE TO WOULD NEVER
SEEN ANYTHING LIKE THIS IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY.
IT USED TO BE A FREE PLACE, WE
BRAG ABOUT IT, BUT IT’S
HAPPENING, AND NOT JUST ONLINE.
THE POLICE COMMISSIONER OF
NEW YORK ANNOUNCED THIS WEEK
THAT POLITICAL PROTESTS HAVE
BEEN BANNED IN AMERICA’S BIGGEST
CITY.
HOW LONG HAVE THEY BEEN BANNED?
WELL, FOR AS LONG AS HIS BOSS
BILL de BLASIO SAYS THEIR
BAND.
SO IT COULD BE A WHILE.
IT’S NICE WHEN VOTERS AREN’T
ALLOWED TO CRITICIZE YOU.
IF THE COMMISSIONER EXPLAINED
THAT’S THE LAW NOW.
"THESE ARE LAWS THAT IF AND
PASSED DOWN THROUGH EXECUTIVE
ORDER."
YEAH, GOT THAT?
PASSED THROUGH EXECUTIVE ORDER.
BUT WAIT, BY DEFINITION,
EXECUTIVE ORDERS AREN’T PASSED.
NO LEGISLATURE SIGNS OFF ON
THEM.
THEY ARE ORDERED.
THAT’S WHY THEIR ORDERS.
WHATEVER, DETAILS, SHUT UP.
YOU THINK SOME CIVIL LIBERTARIAN
JUDGE SOMEWHERE WOULD DO
SOMETHING ABOUT ALL OF THIS.
THEY’RE ALWAYS INVENTING NEW
RIGHTS FOR ILLEGAL ALIENS.
USUALLY THE RIGHT TO FREE STUFF
AT YOUR EXPENSE, THERE ARE A LOT
OF THOSE.
MAYBE WE COULD GET SOME OF THOSE
RIGHTS TOO, BUT NO, YOU’RE JUST
AN AMERICAN, DO WHAT YOU’RE
TOLD.
SHELLEY LUTHER JUST LEARNED THAT
LESSON AND THE HARDEST WAY.
LUTHER OWNS A SALON IN THE CITY
OF DALLAS.
IN MARCH SHE CLOSED HER
BUSINESS, THE GOVERNMENT TOLD
HER TO.
SHE LOST ALL OF HER INCOME WHEN
SHE SHUT IT DOWN BECAUSE THAT’S
WHAT OUR LEADERS DEMANDED.
AND THEN SHE WAITED AND SHE
WAITED AND SHE WAITED.
AND A MONTH LATER, HER BUSINESS
WAS STILL CLOSED AND SHE WAS OUT
OF MONEY.
FINALLY SHE DECIDED SHE HAD NO
CHOICE, HER BACK WAS AGAINST A
WALL’S ON APRIL 24TH TO REOPEN
HER SALON.
THE GOVERNMENT WARNED HER NOT TO
DO THAT.
THEY SENT HER A CITATION.
SHE DID IT ANYWAY.
>> NOW THE SALON OWNER SHELLEY
LUTHER VOWED TO REMAIN OPEN IN
DEFIANCE OF STATE ORDERS.
THE CITATIONS SHE RECEIVED.
>> I COULD BE USED AS AN EXAMPLE
OR THEY’LL GO AWAY, OR I DON’T
KNOW.
I’M NOT GOING TO SHUT DOWN.
>> Tucker: I CAN BE USED AS AN
EXAMPLE, LUTHER SAID.
SHE WAS ASSUMING THAT OTHER
BUSINESS OWNERS IN DALLAS MIGHT
FOLLOW HER LEAD.
BUT THE GOVERNMENT TOOK NOTICE,
THEY WANTED HER TO BE AN EXAMPLE
TOO, BUT IN A VERY DIFFERENT WAY
WAY.
POLICE ARRESTED LUTHER.
IF A DIRECTOR BEFORE A
DALLAS COUNTY JUDGE CALLED ERIC
MOY.
THAT WAS HER BAD LUCK.
HE IS A DEEPLY IRRESPONSIBLE
PERSON.
HE IS A POLITICAL HACK.
HE’S A SELF-DESCRIBED
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ACTIVIST.
HE ONCE CIRCULATED A CHAIN
LETTER DENOUNCING SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE CLARENCE THOMAS AS A
RACE TRAITOR.
HE LECTURED SETTLEMENT SHELLEY L
HOW SHE WAS A BAD PERSON.
>> PUTTING YOUR OWN INTERESTS
AHEAD OF THOSE OF THE COMMUNITY
IN WHICH YOU LIVE.
THAT THEY DISRESPECTED THE
EXECUTIVE ORDERS OF THE STATE,
THE ORDERS OF THE COUNTY IN THIS
CITY.
>> Tucker: WHAT A POMPOUS
FULL.
BUT HE’S GOT A LOT OF POWER,
HE’S A JUDGE BURIED IN SHELLEY
LUTHER WAS SITTING BEFORE HIM.
LUTHER, TO HER ENORMOUS CREDIT,
WAS NOT INTIMIDATED.
INSTEAD OF GROVELING,
APOLOGIZING AND BEGGING
FORGIVENESS, WHICH IS WHAT HE
WANTED, SHE TOLD THE JUDGE WHAT
WAS SO OBVIOUSLY TRUE.
FOR PEOPLE WHO DON’T HAVE
SALARIES THAT ARE GUARANTEED BY
TAXPAYERS, THIS LOCKDOWN AS IT
CONTINUES AS BEEN A CATASTROPHE.
>> I HAVE TO DISAGREE WITH YOU
SIR, WHEN YOU SAY THAT I’M
SELFISH.
BECAUSE FEEDING MY KIDS IS NOT
[INAUDIBLE]
THAT ARE GOING HUNGRY BECAUSE
THEY WOULD RATHER FEED THEIR
KIDS SO IF YOU THINK THE LAW IS
MORE IMPORTANT THAN KIDS GETTING
FED, THEN PLEASE GO AHEAD WITH
THEIR DECISION, BUT I’M NOT
GOING TO SHUT THE SALON.
>> Tucker: EATING MY KIDS IS
NOT SELFISH.
HE WAS UNMOVED BY THIS.
HE’S NOT WORRIED ABOUT FEEDING
HIS KIDS.
HE WENT TO HARVARD LAW SCHOOL.
2007 ARTICLE IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" DESCRIBES
THIS MAN AS SOMEONE "WITH A
WEAKNESS FOR CUBAN CIGARS AND
THE FINEST STEAKS."
WHAT A POSER.
AS A JUDGE, HE HAS CONTINUED TO
SELECT THE SALARY OF ABOUT
$150,000 DRAW THE SHUTDOWN.
HE CAN TAKE THAT FOREVER.
HE CAN AFFORD ALL THE FINEST
STEAKS HE WANTS AT LEAST UNTIL
MEAT SUPPLIES OR NOT.
HE SENTENCED LUTHER TO A WEEK
BEHIND BARS.
THAT’S WHAT’S GOING ON IN DALLAS
TONIGHT.
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS WHO ARE
GOING UNDER, THESE ARE PEOPLE
WITH EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
STRUGGLING TO BUY FOOD, OR BEING
PUNISHED FOR THE CRIME OF
EARNING A LIVING BY
AUTHORITARIAN BUFFOONS, GOONS
WERE LIVING OFF THEIR TAX
DOLLARS.
HOW’S THAT FOR AN ARRANGEMENT?
BEEN WELL, AND THIS IS THE BEST
PART, ACTUAL CRIMINALS ARE GOING
FREE.
THREE WEEKS AGO, THE STATED --
CITY OF DALLAS BEGAN RELEASING
MORE THAN A THOUSAND INMATES
FROM THE GUY JAIL, SOMEWHERE IN
FOR SERIOUS FELONIES.
AUTHORITY SAID THEY HAD NO
CHOICE, THEY HAD TO SAVE THE
INMATES FROM THE VIRUS, THE VERY
SAME VIRUS THAT SHELLEY LUTHER
WILL LIKELY BE EXPOSED TO IN
JAIL WHERE SHE IS NOW.
FOR TRYING TO EARN AN HONEST
LIVING.
IT’S HARD TO BELIEVE ANY OF THIS